so who's my guest this week it's the u.s
attorney gloria allred she calls herself
an avenger for women's rights and one
glance at her cv gives that claim
serious weight
over the last 40 years if there's been a
high-profile sexual assault case in
america it's likely allred's been the
lawyer for some of the victims
a lifelong campaigner for equality she
represented roe after the roe v wade
case
she's not without her critics who say
she's as interested in publicity
as she is justice but undeterred at 81
years old she has no intention of
retiring
so as america grapples with abortion
rights again what does she make of that
supreme court ruling
here's a taste of what's coming up
in 2020 you hired a yellow american
school bus to drive around london near
buckingham palace prince andrew's face
was on it with a sign if you see this
man please ask him to call the fbi to
answer their questions is that mata now
closed or are there other avenues he to
this day
has never agreed
to
sit with the fbi he should be ashamed of
himself
that he refuses to do it he's avoided
he's evaded he's escaped doing it
gloria allred thank you so much for
talking to me for taking some time out
of your busy schedule it's uh it's
wonderful to be able to talk to you
about such a range of issues today and
of course america and women's rights are
global news and i wanted to start by
asking you are you proud to be an
american at the moment
well i'm always very grateful that
my mother came from the uk
to the united states and that i was able
to grow up here and
i do
have a lot of confidence in our system
of
justice and of
rights but
i'm very very disappointed i'm very
outraged
about what has happened recently
with the united states supreme court
decision in roe
v wade but uh it was inevitable
uh given some serious flaws in our
system yes i mean that that's what's
been talked about in terms of the way
the justices are appointed the political
leanings
i suppose i wanted to ask you also with
that decision as an attorney do you have
any sympathy with the view that abortion
shouldn't have been a constitutional
right and that there may be merit in
having state by state laws
there's absolutely no merit whatsoever
in
throwing the decision
that a woman
should or should not be able to have an
abortion
to the states
it should
and has been a constitutional right for
a woman to choose whether or not
to bear a pregnancy and that has been
the law ever since 1973
when roe v wade was decided by the
united states supreme court
and that a woman did have a right to
choose
or not to continue with her pregnancy
at least at certain stages
of her pregnancy
it's very dangerous it is barbaric
it is
just uh an outrage and cruel
to throw this decision
to the states
i'll give you an example emma okay yes
please prior to 1973
and prior to roe v wade decision
many states were criminalizing abortion
so young women like me
who were in their 20s
and had no resources would have to try
to gather some money
to
pay
as someone to provide a back alley
abortion
so i was
raped at gunpoint in mexico
when i went there for a vacation when i
came back to california
in
this was in the late 60s
i found that i was pregnant and that it
was a crime for anyone to assist with an
abortion
uh in california so i had to get some
money together for a back alley
abortionist
who did provide the abortion but left me
in a bathtub hemorrhaging in
a pool of my own blood
and
he said that he could not help me after
the abortion
to take me to 911 hospital
and there
i was taken to a unit
where they would try to save
a woman's life if she was hemorrhaging
from an abortion
police came and interviewed me which was
very frightening to me
because i didn't know
if the name i would give them would be
the name of the real person who provided
it or if i should give a name at all for
fear that he would do something to me if
i gave the name which i didn't
i was packed in ice i had 106 degree
fever i almost died
from an illegal abortion and the nurse
who was anti-choice
said to me i hope this teaches you a
lesson
and i say that it did teach me a lesson
and the lesson is that abortion should
be safe and legal and available and
affordable
and no
woman or girl should have to risk her
life
with an illegal abortion i was just
going to say i mean thank you for for
sharing that i know you've spoken about
your experiences because they are very
relevant and you know highly traumatic
and you don't want to go back to that
place but one of the arguments mounted
by those who are in favor of this
decision is well women can travel women
can go to other states but of course if
they don't have the means like you're
saying
and they don't you know have the
wherewithal or can't get in touch with
those who can help them then they won't
be able to and i just wanted to ask you
are you expecting as an attorney
to to have some clients now who come to
you
who may end up this hasn't happened yet
being prosecuted for either ordering
abortion pills online or trying to cross
state boundaries how concerned are you
about that well you raise another
very important issue actually a number
of important issues so for example
you just mentioned medication abortions
medication abortions
are about half of all of the abortions
in the united states
the anti-choice movement the movement
that believes that a fertilized egg
should have more rights than an adult
woman is trying to interfere
with medication abortions
for example to suggest to legislators
that the pill can only be sent if a
doctor is seen in person which many
women are not able to do it also invades
their privacy because we are also
concerned by the anti-choice forces
trying to obtain
medical records to find out when a woman
is menstruating you also mentioned the
right to travel to other states emma
that's a significant issue there are
many poor women who can't afford child
care these are just some of the problems
that are now existing
for a woman to travel to another state
of course wealthy women will always be
able to travel to another state or
another country like canada to get an
abortion in indeed and and on those
issues and the complications that are
going to arise
do you think joe biden has done enough
to demonstrate to the women of america
who are of your view and are worried
about this
that this is not okay that this is not
the america that he wants to preside
over
has he done enough
i think that the president knows that
there are so many challenges now
facing women and girls because of this
dangerous decision
he has very limited ability to do
anything
the main challenge is that we're going
to have to get
everyone to come out to vote in the
upcoming election we must remember in
november is our clarion call our clarion
cry
for justice what that means is that
pro-choice voters are going to have to
vote in both federal and state elections
for pro-choice elected officials and we
must throw out of office
the anti-choice compulsory pregnancy
crowd
that is passing these restrictive
and dangerous
laws in the states and also
is causing essentially paralysis in the
congress and the united states senate we
must elect more pro-choice united states
senators and
representatives in the house of
representatives as well
i mean i was minded to bring up to you a
very striking remark she's known for
them from fran lieberwicz the writer and
commentator she's recently compared the
republican party to the taliban
regarding control over women's bodies
what do you make of that comparison
well i can understand why she said it
i mean because this is controlling
women's choices and their lives it's
often been said emma
that if we can't control if we cannot
control our lives from the skin in we
cannot control our lives from the skin
out and this is about even more than
reproductive choice because
not being able to choose what we do with
our own bodies
means that there is going to be
interference
with our educational opportunities our
business opportunities our physical
opportunities our emotional
opportunities and it is going to have a
draconian impact on each and every
woman's life
we cannot go back we will not go back
and we must have a passion to fight back
to win back our rights
i wanted to just come to norma mccorvey
who was row in this case
you later represented her you worked
with her but she later despite having
become once her name was known
synonymous with this case that granted
women until recently
you know constitutional rights to
abortion she changed sides publicly she
went against choice she went against
abortion and then it was revealed that
she'd been paid by that side of the
debate to assume that position just
before she died that was revealed
did you know she had been paid what and
what did you make of that whole episode
having known the woman who was known as
roe look every woman gets to make the
choice that she wants to make i don't
control any woman's choice i don't try
to do that
that's what the anti-choice people do
so yes was it disappointing
of course
but you know did i try to coerce her
that's not my role
uh it's not anybody's role and but she
admitted the truth in the end i'm glad
that she did it let me bring you to
another area of your work which is
representing victims of sexual abuse and
sexual assault because recently gillane
maxwell was sentenced to 20 years for
recruiting and trafficking 14 girls for
sexual abuse of course
in connection to to jeffrey epstein
it's very striking although a woman has
gone to prison but we still don't know
the names of the other men involved
yeah i have no idea what the prosecutors
have in mind federal prosecutors hold
their cards very very close to their
vest
and they're known for that so i have no
idea what they're planning next or
if they're planning anything else
in reference to prosecuting any other
individuals who might have been involved
with ms maxwell and with jeffrey epstein
just following on from that again about
whether something is closed or there
could be you know further
actions because of your experience i
wanted to ask you but also because of
something you did and coming to prince
andrew in 2020 you hired a yellow
american school bus to drive around
london near buckingham palace i know you
remember it some others will remember it
prince andrew's face was on it saying
with a sign if you see this man please
ask him to call the fbi to answer their
questions and as you say because you
were representing some of jeffrey
epstein's victims earlier this year
prince andrew did come to a settlement
with virginia du frey
prince andrews always denied any
wrongdoing is that mata now closed or
are there other avenues
i did that because i wanted prince
andrew
to cooperate
and give an interview to the
fbi
about what he knew about jeffrey epstein
anything else they wanted to ask about
him since prince andrew stayed in many
residences owned by jeffrey epstein and
where young girls were present
he never did that in other words he gave
an interview to the bbc
that of course was not under oath and it
was a complete catastrophe from a pr
point of view i wanted him to sit with
the fbi and testify under oath or even
if not under oath his duty legally would
be to tell the truth which he had no
duty to do to the bbc although it would
have been nice
i don't know if he did it or not
he never did it
the civil settlement that you mentioned
had nothing to do
with the criminal case being prosecuted
against ms maxwell
and nothing to do
with anything but the criminal justice
system he to this day
has never agreed
to
sit with the fbi he should be ashamed of
himself that he refuses to do it he's
avoided he's evaded
he's escaped doing it
now
the criminal case against ms maxwell
will go on appeal
but
i say it's never too late for him to sit
with the prosecutors they themselves
said that he was not
providing an interview you're saying you
know he didn't sit down with the fbi
that's what's understood and that what
why should he still have a conversation
with the fbi to help which case
well it could open up new cases that is
provide evidence for new cases right so
look
anyone who may have any information that
is relevant to crimes against children
should volunteer
to speak to law enforcement fbi
state law enforcement anywhere else
not have to be
drag kicking and screaming or just try
to avoid it completely perhaps he would
say he doesn't have any information i
mean he's not here to to speak to what
you're saying he has always denied
wrongdoing but perhaps well that's
complete that's perhaps his reason that
is complete
and utter
nonsense that he has
no information whatsoever he stayed in
the residence of jeffrey epstein with
jeffrey epstein when young girls were
coming and going from that residence in
manhattan he also
visited other residences
of jeffrey epstein other properties we
know that that's a matter of fact
not speculation to say that he has no
information
is just not true
and
even he has not
dared to say it is completely false
gloria when you are on the case for
people largely it's been women
lots of the cases you work on we never
hear about but there are some very high
profile cases
you are known for your ability your
mastery to get attention to to pull
stunts to call press conferences whether
it's a school bus whether it's get
people in front of a camera i'm sure you
have to work with those women as well to
get them ready for those sorts of
situations
what do you make of some of the
criticism that you have faced about
that approach that that that being one
of your hallmarks if you like emma there
are many people who think
that women should have to suffer in
silence
i'm not one of them
i think that women should have a voice
they should be able to speak truth to
power
they should be able to
speak out
about the injustices against them in an
appropriate case
depending on what their goal is
and only after they've been advised of
the benefits and risks of that decision
which is what i do have you been
disappointed at points by some of the
men that you've come up against because
maybe you were a fan of their work you'd
enjoyed their music you'd watch their
i don't know sporting performance have
you had that moment that some people
have when they hear about somebody when
they're found guilty and they thought no
not that person have you had that
not really
no because uh you know i i'm just very
goal oriented for my clients who are
victims
i know that many celebrities
lead double lives or triple lives where
the character or the brand that they've
created
are not who they are in real life
and so i don't buy into the fantasy
you can only be disappointed if you have
expectations that are different than the
reality
my expectations are
that
often celebrities
will take advantage of their celebrity
status against vulnerable victims and
often against their own fans
uh which
you know is very disturbing
because i always feel that celebrities
and powerful people
should feel very blessed about the
privileges
that they have because they are
celebrities and i often say about those
celebrity attorneys who
represent their clients who are being
accused they represent the hollywood bad
boys
and i represent the women they hurt well
it definitely sounds like it's changed
you know your whole view of the world
that we live in and given it a
completely different complexion just
finally in that documentary about your
life that i'm sure many people will have
seen on netflix
in 2015 i believe you said you'd had no
holidays in 40 years
have you had one since i'm hoping
perhaps a glimmer of a break here and
there well there's no
holiday
from injustice oh come on gloria a
little bit a little bit
a little bit of a break when i'm six
feet under when that day comes it will
come for all of us
maybe
i'll have some rest at that time
although
i am
considering many ways that perhaps i can
help even from the grave
but
we have to fight back for women it's
my duty
i am blessed to have the privilege
to help others to rise up to become
empowered and that's what this is all
about and i
do not need rest
if anything we have a saying emma
that women become
more radical as they get older
the women's movement is unique on all
movements in that way
and yes i see even more need
after 47 years of practicing law than i
did when i began to practice so i do
have a passion for justice i have no
interest in holidays
i only have interest in winning justice
and that is what i will continue to do
gloria i like that i look forward to
getting even more radical and busy as i
get older and that's because of our life
experience it's not because of any
women's studies class we've ever had
women recognize what is wrong in their
lives and a matter of fact if when i
visit some women in in nursing homes and
old age homes they they pick up their
canes and they say gloria don't stop
when these men attack you just continue
and fight harder those women know the
truth about their lives emma and i am
fighting for all women young old i don't
care their color their religion their
ethnic origin we want them to rise up
and become empowered and fight back
choose your battles carefully but fight
back
and you can win justice
well on that i i think also the uh the
idea of of growing old not disgracefully
but you know getting more angry and more
active is one and it's often said women
definitely made the personal political
as well gloria all read thank you very
much thank you emma and thank you so
much for being with us until we meet
again take care and goodbye
[Music]
you